no more sand i haven't recovered from
dune yet oh no this is also a heavy
water extraction planet it's tatooine as
well damn it but seriously they're
billions upon billions of planets in the
galaxy so why don't we apparently insist
on colonizing the ones with no [ __ ]
water fine arrakis has the spice and
tatooine has 15 spin-off shows but
what's your excuse halo some bs resource
like heavy hydrogen my hands are healthy
with the blood of unsc marines
disrespecting the dead by bragging about
their remains staining your hands we
gail us with a number of your war
stories disrespecting a veteran as
they're disrespecting the dead by
bragging about their remains staining
their hands but war need not be the
answer forcing torchwood here to put on
this ridiculously mustache twirling
english accent there's another
difference between spartans and marines
marines can be killed if he's
insinuating that spartans can not be
killed i'd like to refer him to 2006
me's abysmal online kd ratio noob
spartans aren't human
they're faster stronger smarter
excitement there i didn't sign up for
this cliche seriously why is this a
thing how many things do we actually
sign up for i doubt he specifically
signed up for breathing but he's not
complaining about that magical the
galaxy's highest concentration of heavy
hydrogen fine but sand planets are still
dumb
toasting with root balls quan finds a
spot to dug away but is barely missed by
weapon fire which made me assume the
aliens knew where she was and were hot
on her tail then she fires a flare and
leaves a smoke trail that essentially
points out her location but she's still
not exploded i guess if there was any
question about who will survive episode
1 we've got our answer
[Music]
so the kid runs across the compound and
warns general hobbit isn't that
inefficient time is precious while he
runs why doesn't someone raise the alarm
ring a bell torch a pyre bongagong do
something fear is 25 52 and we're still
using ak-47s
quan not only survives this it barely
breaks her [ __ ] stride this is a
pretty badass entrance but why did the
covenant decide to park way out in the
boonies and walk to the colonists
instead of landing nearer or just
blowing them up from the sky general han
has been unleashed these mounted guns
onto the enemy and it doesn't do
anything well it does but not until the
spartans use their weapons later which
is really dumb it may be the most
infuriating scene of this entire episode
give me a minute
yep i just watched the whole thing and
came back to tell you i'm still
unreasonably angry about it are we gonna
die no of course not unfounded optimism
the one-sided nature of this battle
makes it about as much fun to watch as
playing a game on legendary mode before
you have a clue what any of the controls
are mission accomplished in this shot we
see his leg is trapped under the vehicle
but back here was clearly visible faker
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i guess i have to remove a sin
based on how much the show fragging
nails master chief's armor but also
three-point landing cliche
engage show went with silver instead of
having the balls to pick between red or
blue pulling out a gun so you can shoot
someone in the head after just putting
away a gun that is equally as capable of
shooting someone in the head the
spartans are the pinnacle of military
prowess the personification of combat
evolved if you will so why wouldn't they
bring a ton of ammo to fight the
covenant dude runs out and has to opt
for a pole he didn't even use his
remaining two grenades before stabbing
at these guys with a massive metal straw
here's an odd moment where a spartan
gets a badass alien weapon uses it to
annihilate the enemy and then casually
discards it as if it were a banana peel
keep that [ __ ] and destroy also how do i
remember plasma pistols losing all
pigment after shooting them
we've just watched children slaughtered
bodies disfigured and lives brutally
ended if you think this show is setting
these two up for a happy reunion you are
wrong
also needlessly sacrificing yourself by
ignoring the advantages afforded by a
long-range weapon by running directly at
your enemy especially when that enemy
only has a short-range weapon available
to them he sure was determined to give
his daughter a tragic origin story
wasn't he teasing us with only a couple
of seconds of what is almost the halo
theme why play with perfection that is
far too many industries also not bungee
shocking to see that after a further 500
years of pop culture humanity still
hasn't learned to not touch the
mysterious cave dwelling floaty artifact
thingies until you have a better idea of
what it [ __ ] does ah reach what a
beautiful planet i bet it looks lovely
in the fall the security committee is
looking for an excuse to cut your
funding politics the unnecessary pickle
in my otherwise enjoyable sci-fi action
adventure sandwich look i like pickles
i'm just saying it's weird that they're
the standard and people who don't like
them have to specify that they don't
want them pickles are politics we've
been fighting these alien creatures for
years and we still have no idea what
they want where to find them on how to
beat them well let's start with not
defunding the only thing you know for a
fact can kick-set aliens asses shall we
i told you that was a non-starter we
have posed active development thinking
that conducting your forbidden science
experiments in a room that is not even
20 feet away from the main entrance to
your lab is a good idea
i really hope that whatever's in this
bag will be important at some point in
the show she's lugged it around since
her mad dash from the forest and the
only reason to cling to a bag while
you're fleeing alien attack after alien
attack is if it contains your snacks
your animal companion your drugs your
porn or your whoopi you people can make
video look like anything great point so
why does the unsc need quan for this
video they're about to give the order to
kill her so why don't they just use that
lack of morals to dress someone up as a
colonist and pay them to say what they
want especially as there are no
survivors to prove otherwise what are
you doing scanning the integrity of all
biointerfaces for evidence of
abnormalities and the scan just so
happens to be in this very room where
you're a prisoner which will force us to
have a conversation bringing coffee into
a butchering facility to someone who is
actively dismembering an alien body
halsey's always been single-minded work
is the only thing that matters referring
to your ex-wife and the mother of your
child by her last name so that you can
temporarily hide her identity from an
audience you shouldn't know is watching
sometimes you have to make hard choices
to get good results good results not
great certainly not super amazing just
you know the good sort of results truly
worth murdering for i don't look at
pictures of my mom that often but skip
how much longer are we stuck in here you
know she's asking this to plan when she
can ch in peace after that horrible tin
meal can the girl survived this i
thought you wanted her dad dr halsey
would be a spartan at tv sins this
simply sealed within reach atmosphere
panel with the conveniently crucial to
be things wait you had to fuel up the
emergency pelicans why weren't they
ready to go you just have them sitting
there with empty [ __ ] tanks i wonder
all those colonists died i'm superseding
those orders she's been talking for a
while now but the silver team just got
to her i'm sure this means they have
some sort of in-ear calm or something
but why would she be talking about
disobeying order so loudly if she can
whisper through their helmet comms
wait what i had to play through four
halo games and wait 11 years to get a
moment like this so many midnight launch
lines waded in so many grunts smooshed
under warthogs this show has the
audacity to do master chief's face
reveal in the first episode i understand
why you did it but i can't help but feel
cheated the next generation of halo fans
has it easy and your trespass paramount
shall not be forgiven also when did he
pull off the head sock thingy because
the other sparty people had head sock
thingies his hair should be a wreck by
the way get me thermal imaging on the
contour sounds like a good idea that
should have been done far before now
disconnect the ai autopilot
failsafe using the shout it louder
approach to teaching a civilian how to
tamper with the ai on your super
advanced spaceship
this works
i hope you plan on moving that warthog
over before detonating those charges
because those cars will find any reason
to flip over forcing me to go frame by
frame just to find this boring image of
nature if these are john's memories why
are we looking over his shoulder show
won't let me play for another hour
despite being desperate to know what
happens next you're not my mom paramount
now
now remove your helmet yeah let someone
else deal a professor has sticky hands
you say like cheat i'm saying you don't
wash your hands oh i know what the
ladies like over a kill double kill
triple kill over a kill
i lift things up and put them down
this is sparta
random war miranda the future of
humanity it doesn't matter what you
think i think he's having memories i'm
not sure what to do with my hands
let's face it this is not the worst
thing you've got me doing